welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the darksaber has returned as
the toy wanted by everyone and no one in
the star wars universe now weighing
heavily in the hands of the mandalorian
din jaren the book of boba vet or
whatever they want to call these shows
that are all really just grogu and
friends and now according to some its
rules of succession have a deeper more
mystic weight than we realize further
complicated who may ultimately wield
this weapon so who is gonna end up with
the darksaber will mandalore ever
recover from the wasteland it now is
well to truly understand the darksaber's
rules and power we really have to
revisit its history from the beginning
it was first introduced back in january
2010 in season 2 episode 12 of clone
wars in the hands of mandalorian death
watch leader priya vizla also voiced by
john favreau this lightsaber was stolen
from your jedi temple by my ancestors
during the fall of the old republic
since then many jedi have died upon its
blade
prepare yourself to join them now at
that time dave filoni explained this
weapon was designed at the request of
george lucas himself to replace priebus
love fighting obi-wan with just a
vibrably now instead with a sick ancient
black-bladed lightsaber with a crackle
of energy given a sing-songy hum like a
tuning fork and flat like an actual
sword unlike the all-rounded lightsabers
that most other jedi use now years after
this star wars is like holy [ __ ] we
should be settling this as a toy so it
showed up again of course in clone wars
season 5 when in episode 15 the death
watch joined maul and a plot to take the
throne of mandalore a plot that
backfired when maul betrayed priebisla i
challenge you
one warrior to another and only the
strongest shall rule mandalore they
dueled it was awesome but maul won like
you said
only the strongest
shall rule
now boca tan crees also at that time a
member of the death watch at this moment
refused to join maul and defected maul
then used the dark saber to murder the
dethroned leader of mandalore duchess
satine boca tan sister right in front of
satine's boo obi-wan then darth sidious
arrived considered maul to be too much a
rival killed his brother savageo press
and then dueled maul two red lightsabers
versus maul's redblade in the darksaber
sidious prevailed and tortured maul the
last we saw of the darksaber on clone
wars but the son of dathomir comic
series catches up maul's history with
the dark saver from that point the
darksaber was recovered by maul's super
commandos and maul used this darksaber
against general grievous then maul
returned to daftmire to help his mother
the nightsister towson but fled that
battle as talzin sacrificed herself
killed by grievous now chronologically
the next time we see the dark saber is
in rebels in season 3 when maul lured
ezra bridger into its cave temple in
dathomir where maul had been collecting
artifacts from his past is that a
lightsaber
indeed
yes but not like any that you would know
if your mandalorian friend was here
she could explain it to you sabine wren
and kane and jairus rescue ezra from
those night sister spirits and the dark
saber blade ends up in sabine's hands
but at this point sabine feels a bit
awkward with this weapon because her
family house wren considers her a
traitor to the mandalorian people who at
this point had aligned with the empire
and in this season we finally hear the
full backstory of the darksaber told
from the mandalorian warrior from the
protectors then rao legend tells that it
was created over a thousand years ago by
tar vizsla the first mandalorian ever
inducted into the jedi order
after his passing the jedi kept the
savior in their temple that was until
members of house vizsla snuck in and
liberated it they used the saber to
unify the people and strike down those
who would oppose them
one time they ruled all of mandalore
wielding this blade
this saber is an important symbol to
that house and respected by the other
clans but realizing that this darksaber
can be useful to rally a whole army of
mandalorians to the rebel cause kanan
jairus offers to train sabine with this
weapon it's heavier than i thought
energy constantly flows through the
crystal you're not fighting with a
simple blade as much as you are
directing a current of power
your thoughts your actions they become
energy they flow through the crystal as
well and become a part of the blade the
blades will be drawn to each other that
sword is old heavy but powerful
respect its strength sabine reluctantly
learns the basic forms of lightsaber
combat and she starts to get the hang of
it the blade feels lighter
you're connecting with it it's becoming
a part of you suggesting that the
blade's physical weight changes
depending on its connection to the
wielder something that we saw in this
recent episode of the mandalorian where
din jiren struggled to lift its weight
meaning he did not have as strong of a
connection to this weapon despite
winning it properly now losing your hair
is stressful for the guys i know going
through it it's one of the parts of
aging that can make you feel older when
you realize sam raimi spider-man came
out
20 years ago well two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
but with keeps you can get quality
expert care without ever visiting a
doctor's office or pharmacy keeps offers
generic versions of the only two fda
approved hair loss products out there
but at half the cost of your local
pharmacy though you never have to go
into a doctor's office keeps as a
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality easily subscribe to keeps and
get refill reminders so you'll never run
low on the products to take care of your
hair hair loss stops with keeps to get
50 off your first order go to keeps.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description that's k-e-e-p-s dot com new
rockstars sabine shortly after this
reunites with their mother ursa wren and
brother tristan who at first resent
sabine for turning the rins into outcast
to the rest of the mandalorians versa
asks about the darksaber where did you
get it
from maul
you want it from him in combat uh not
exactly then you have no claim to it
well i'm holding it that's a pretty good
claim anyone can hold the darksaber the
trick is keeping it along with your head
the first time this combat succession
rule is spelled out so explicitly but
while ursa gives the darksaber to the
imperial governor of mandalore gar saxon
in an attempt to try to get their family
name back in his good graces he ends up
saying nah screw that you guys still
suck and sabine duels him using ezra's
lightsaber to earn back the dark saber
still she does not yet feel worthy i'm
not mandalore's leader
but i'll find the person who is so at
the beginning of season four sabine
random meets bogatan crees who also at
first feels uneasy about accepting the
dark saber bokotam was made regent by
the jedi before the end of the clone war
she's still seen by many as mandalore's
rightful ruler this belongs to you
i had my chance to rule and i failed
i am not my sister
[Music]
i am not the leader you seek this is
several years after the events of clone
wars season seven in which bogutan and
ahsoka tano take back mandalore briefly
from maul but this is right as order 66
goes out so the empire takes it all over
anyway but back here in rebel season 4
after they rescue sabine's father ulrich
and destroy the anti-mandalorian weapon
that sabine helped them design sabine
convinces poketan to take the blade you
have the wisdom of a ruler
there's no one i trust to wield the dark
saver more than you and i am not alone
non-bislay's with you clan rook is with
you van elder is with you
the protectors are with you clan wren is
with you now i understand why the saber
came to me
it came to me so i could pass it to you
i accept this sword for my sister
for my clan
and for all of mandalore
what a great moment a moment that takes
place a few years before the battle of
yavin and the whole turning point of the
galactic civil war hopes were high that
bogatan's leadership meant victory for
mandalore too but nope
and years after that flashback took
place the mandalorian season one finale
showed moff gideon with the darksaber in
hand the same day he'd bragged about the
great purge of mandalore and that night
of a thousand tears though bokutan
survived having the darksaber stolen
from her showing up in season two hoping
to retake mandalore despite the place
being a [ __ ]
so she joins amanda's rescue mission for
grogu and moff gideon reveals what her
real intentions probably are mesmerizing
isn't it
used to belong to bo katan
yes i know you've been traveling with
boca tan i'm guessing that bogatan and
her boarding party have arrived at the
bridge
seeking me or
more accurately
this you see she wants
this
do you know why
because it brings power
whoever wields this sword
has the right to lay claim to the
mandalorian throne mando ends up
defeating and disarming gideon himself
and gideon later laughs when bogatan
cannot take the darksaber herself it
must be won
in battle
in order for her to wield the darksaber
again
she would need to defeat you in combat a
yield it's yours
oh
no
it doesn't work that way
the dark saber
doesn't have power the story does
without that blade
she's a pretender
to the throne
he's right which brings us to now when
mando brings the dark saber to the
armorer who confirms this if however it
is not one in combat and falls into the
hands of the undeserving
it will be a curse unto the nation
[Music]
mandalore will be laid to waste and its
people scattered to the four winds the
armorer even singles out bokuton as an
example of one of these undeserving
wielders bokotan is a cautionary tale
she once laid claim to rule mandalore
based purely on blood
and the sword you now possess
but it was gifted to her and not won by
creed bocaton crees was born of a mighty
house but they lost sight of the way her
rule ended in tragedy they lost their
way
and we lost our world so the armorer
deepens the succession rule into radical
religious belief she believes that by
accepting the dark saber from sabine
wren without winning it in real combat
bo katan triggered a curse that led to
the empire bombing mandalore in purging
most of their best car but if that's
really the case why was sabine's passing
of the dark saber to poketon depicted as
such a triumphant homecoming i mean
other than that being part of an
animated show years earlier before they
figured out they want to do something
else and everything being from a certain
point of view but also why did sabine
begin connecting with the dark saber
before winning it back properly from gar
saxon after she really had just picked
it up in a cave and does this combat
succession rule mean that pre-vizsla in
each and every generation of bizlas had
to fight savagely with each other father
versus son both of them equally wanting
the weapon in order to pass the dark
saber down oh dad i don't wanna do this
you're gonna fight your papa fight me
look there is a lot we do not know about
the armorer and whether she's telling
the complete truth other than she leads
this group of super culty mandalorians
called the watch and the watch was an
outgrowth of the death watch whose
headquarters were on concordia in clone
wars and now the armor confirms that
they survived the bombing because they
were on concordia this is the same group
just before and after some really dark
[ __ ] you'll notice her helmet has
distinct horns similar to those of maul
and the death watch members who didn't
defect with bo katan who stood with maul
during clone wars season 7 wore red and
black armor with horned helmets in the
style of maul the armorer could have
been one of those mall loyalists who
despised boca ton who broke away from
them i assume we'll learn more when
these two mandalorians meet and i cannot
wait for that conversation but based on
mando struggling with the darksaber's
weight it is clear that what kanan
jairus said about the weight fluctuating
based on its connection with the wielder
is true however mando's struggling with
it despite winning it in proper combat
versus mob gideon so that whole
succession rule might be less of a form
of mysticism inside the weapon than it
is really power in the eyes of other
mandalorians a ritual that the people
consider to be sacred because again as
mob gideon said the dark saber
doesn't have power the story does and in
that moment mandalorians denjarin and
coska reeves and everyone else present
would know that bo katan once again
received the sword without winning it
properly and now with this critical
second chance she's trying to earn she
doesn't want there to be any doubt in
her claim to mandalore so ultimately who
will wield the darksaber who should
wield it din jaren the current reigning
champion in the line of combat
succession paz vizsla the ancestral heir
to it bogatan crees the disgraced leader
seeking redemption sabine wren who's
still alive still out there and will
appear in live action on the ahsoka
spin-off series reportedly played by
natasha liu diesel i mean to be honest
really none of these mandalorians sound
like suitable wielders for the weapon to
me they've all had their chance and to
each of them the darksaber said
not you i mean it makes sense to all
mandalorians of this generation the
darksaber represents ruin division bad
luck something destined to fall in the
wrong hands this is why din giants dip
in the living waters of mandalore are
going to be so important because we may
finally get an answer to this
darksaber's true nature like why is its
hum more of a song why is its blade flat
and it's edged cracked why is its color
black i mean according to kane and
jairus there is a kyber crystal in that
hilt but what of experience did tar
vizsla have on ilum to unearth an ebony
colored crystal it can't just be that
tar was a goth i mean with a name like
tar really i see two futures for the
dark saber one it could end up in the
hands of grogu a bit of george lucasian
poetry for this latest foundling to have
a shared custody between the jedi and
the mandalorians to inherit the artifact
of the mandalorian jedi tarvisla since
neither the dark saber nor grogu appear
in the sequel films that could explain
their shared absence but based on the
design the color the unusual nature of
this lightsaber it feels like a
violation of nature i think a more
fitting destiny for the dark saber is
for it and it's black olson kyber
crystal to be destroyed permanently its
edge is cracked as if it wants to be
destroyed as if it is trying to tear
itself apart it has made itself a pain
in the ass for everyone who has carried
it really it's less of an excalibur than
a ring of sauron it has never truly
united any mandalorians we have followed
on any of these titles really it has
just kept them at war with each other
and i think the recent episode of the
mandalorian hinted at this by pointing
out that the darksaber's hilt is made of
besguard the hilt is of a quality of
bhaskar i have never seen before which
the armorer said in reference to the
spear mandalorian steel is meant for
armor not weapons therefore the dark
saber's existence is a violation to
their own creed so ultimately it was not
that bo-katan wielded a darksaber
unjustly when she tried to unite the
mandalorians at the end of rebels it was
that she had to hold a sword at all to
do that so preach living waters of
mandalore tell denjar and to freak and
melt that dark saber down into another
toy for grogu it's the only thing in
this world that's brought us any good by
the way you may notice i am wearing a
custom boba fett design that you can get
exclusively at newrockstarsmerch.com and
if you live in the chicago area you can
come see us live on friday february 11th
at 8pm italia hall a special live event
that new rockstars is doing we almost
never do these you can come meet us in
person tell me to my face how stupid you
think my theories are please don't do
that or be nice about it either way
ticket link in the description get your
hands tickets are going fast follow me
at eavos following your rockstars
subscribe to the rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you